Universal gives its own logo 24 seconds
of screen time despite knowing several
other production logos we're waiting in
line behind it and stretching our total
opening logo time to a whopping 55
seconds there's been a war between orcs
and humans for as long as can be
remembered or as long as it's been since
Tolkien created the orcs were blatantly
stealing for this game movie also
narration but there was once a time when
we did not even know who our enemy was
we just said you've been fighting with
humans as long as you can remember so
how do you remember the time before that
when you didn't even know your enemy but
in the beginning how could we have known
know what you've given me three
statements so far two about knowing what
about wondering how you could have known
and already I think I see the problem
with this movie this asshole has a
couple of tusks rings which means the
real antagonist here is the scourge of
tooth decay a pregnant wife makes me
imagine this couples gross gross orc sex
which probably involved the Fifty Shades
of Warcraft sex manual how are the great
Durotan named his son I assume she knows
it's a son because of some orc magic
that goes unexplained I highly doubt she
has access to an orc to sound so many
clans in one place / Laughing Skull
mikroc expositional time-wasting client
naming Jesus movie John Carter much
question why must the portal be 200 feet
high in order to walk an army of men no
taller than 8 or 9 or maybe 10 feet
maybe he wouldn't need to wipe out so
many races if he made these things more
practical you are for my magic why any
life does it have to be terrified
anthropomorphic life why not just breed
a few million orc mice specifically for
portal purposes not that I condone
wanton Mouse murder just seems like it'd
be a lot easier or plants even the enemy
is weak when we arrive we will take them
as fuel is this Warcraft or a gritty
reboot of Monsters Inc oh that was all
just space travel
I guess this discount avatar guardians
of Mars Bowl was already tired less than
eight minutes in sorry Duncan Jones moon
was awesome and that's the best thing I
can say about this Warcraft movie main
character adult male orc gets in trouble
for bringing his pregnant wife on a raid
which is how the movie chooses to show
me it has rules or something but mostly
just a way to give our main characters
obstacles and antagonists if this guy
knew this rule last night then give me
some scene explaining why he's gonna
break the rules to bring her along
anyway but no last night you gave us
hilarious pillow talk about
naming in fat bellies this answers the
question if a tree falls in the middle
of a CGI war portal do I get less
interested in the movie as a whole the
answer is surprisingly probably hmm
she's going into labor right now this
movie is aggressively annoying a new
warrior for the Horde looks kind of
small do you think he can hold one of
those big hammers already also let's all
forget about how angry we were at him
for bringing his pregnant wife on the
hunt and rejoice in this baby that would
have been stillborn weren't not for the
convenient nearby deer in this other
dimension of space we just teleported -
yep this is a title screen which means
you've learned all you need to know
about these creatures in the last 9
minutes which is in point of fact
hilariously untrue but whatever in case
you confused it for someplace real and
not ripped off from Lord of the Rings
it's good to see the dwarves thriving in
the lonely mountain again after cleaning
up what must have been scatter strophic
piles of smog it's a boom stick let me
guess you got it as smart in case you
confused it for CGI city number 7 also
even though you're giving us town names
each time we see a new one you're still
not giving me any relative distance
which would greatly help me understand
if any of these places are Friend or Foe
Vulcan mind-meld meet your videogame
counterpart dad son I told you not to
expound in public since some dark forces
when it's strong it almost has a smell
fart magic try to carefully you talk to
your queen you are my sister first these
people look nothing alike and yes they
could be step-siblings but I feel the
way this movie is written someone would
say yes I am your sister first but the
blood of my father is different from
yours also the last two minutes has only
been a stone's throw from all these
characters just looking into the camera
and telling me their relationships to
each other discount pop peak City
manufactured by Rivendell industries a
subsidiary of toko Lothar Burroughs
Jesus Christ there are so many
characters with so many weird names and
so many different locales
how can you summon the energy to keep oh
look the Martian is on so wait what was
I talking about again and why is my
blu-ray player filled with accidental
bullet holes look
you have an h2 bit well we saw each
other last week so they have bookcases
hanging from the ceiling here which are
four forth of your levitation students
only making a dove them why not
you've ripped everything else off from
those movies oh you meant Gollum okay
Carolyn with not ripping off Lord of the
Rings then it's good to see those are I
need your guidance okay it sounds like
this movie is about to get medieval our
asses also ah man they dragged Ben
Foster to this hello
Guardian later this chick will tell
Khadgar everything he needs to know to
win this movie just not now because
timing is not this smokey chick strong
suit
glowing tattoo of detection will factor
here and nowhere else in the movie after
getting thrown around the library and
falling from a decent height this kid
remains virtually unscathed
the magic unlike any other it feeds on
life itself it pollutes the user
twisting everything it touches
it promises great power but it exacts a
terrible price Khadgar made a big deal
about how the Guardian needed to explain
what this power was but now that he has
I wonder why that asshole Khadgar
couldn't have explained it I mean sure
they had to visit this guy just not to
explain this is what I'm saying
also you know just once I'd like to see
great power cause absolutely no moral or
physical problems yeah sure let's just
transport right into the middle of the
throne room that won't cause any sort of
alarm at all just to protect this room
my lord I am the cardia just in case you
were sleeping through that hole some in
The Guardian bit from earlier because
like me you were asleep here's this or
strangling or throwing also only CGI
horses were harmed in the making of this
film
ah confusing battle cliche ex machina
instead of just letting this guy to
death this dude decides to show his
amazing strength by throwing him across
the forest which is decidedly less
deadly or calm screen this kind of magic
makes me wonder why the orcs are even
still around to battle the humans at all
I mean Jesus that's Ark of the Covenant
level magic utterly wasting your story's
direwolves I refuse to believe a horse
would willingly gallop for a rider three
times the size and weight of said horse
I wondering why go then brought Paula
Patton on this journey other than the
fact that she's Paula Patton true she's
smart and fierce but she's a worthless
prisoner that impedes travel and the
only reason I can think of to bring her
and so that she can help the humans out
later are the horses in this world made
up in iron look how far that orc flew
I'm gonna shoulder you unconscious
serious question do you think Chris
would notice if I stopped watching this
and just made up the rest of my sins cuz
while I'm not gonna do that
I bet I could then he wouldn't notice
that's how stupid this movie is have you
a name corona
she calls herself Khurana okay cool but
why do you answer the ruler on her
behalf with a smile
also discount Kimura is named Garona
because the subtlest differences in
copycat movies are the best should I
mean where you come from the sistine
maps also we put a map on our ceiling
because we thought that was practical
and also we are not a smart race but how
did you learn our language Oh take
prisoner for the game I learned from
them so the prisoners taught you every
word of English in this short time
you've been in this world you have
allowed the small cheese to kill your
warriors you thought this problem ended
long ago but people are still to
thrace's how to cook an orc maybe it
would be a great cheese how the do you
know lady he's a goddamn newborn maybe
he'll be a great whore denying stirring
you don't know you're just saying you
think you should say to make your orc
man feel good about his worthless son
she challenges you already or he's just
a baby that makes baby sounds the Ronis
cell is perfectly placed for the
specific night's moon watchers
why is there a centrally located cage in
the middle of all these prison cells is
this one for celebrities the voice like
fire and ash just as this movie is about
to explain something a ticket opens a
gate and the Guardian turns into an
eagle and flies out the skylight that I
think is there in order to kill the
vampires they keep overnight light comes
darkness from darkness right that's
clear what's clear is that the person
who wrote in this book is also the
person who wrote this movie also it's
absolute gibberish even if it's coming
from some kind of ancient text still
gibberish and factually untrue remember
when we would track blood dogs through
the frost wing Jun we're 40 minutes in
and we've hardly Warcraft it they should
change the name of this movie to
reminisce crafts wherever golden works
his magic
Aladdin dice Durotan is the only orc
with the wherewithal to notice that goal
Dan's magic kills the light that
surrounds it even though it's extremely
clear that is how it draws its power the
ancient equivalent of texting while
driving
he wishes to lie with me oh so you're
totally blind about the mage wanting to
sleep with you but when Lothar was
obviously looking at you with my eyes
you didn't understand what that meant
okay gate
nothing I'm looking at even looks like a
gate let alone a great gate it mostly
looks like Six Flags and Costner's the
postman apocalypse the north there's a
Black Rock that touches the sky it's
okay you can say Mountain you know all
the other words damn Mario was laying
waste to this entire map also though
movie saves money on the map sequence by
incorporating some advanced civilization
game animations the fact that this is
supposed to be a dwarf I'm a soldier I
bet if you cut every line where someone
just says what they
are you shaving good 20 minutes off this
movie's run time sounds like a trap
it is not could be Akbar I mean Lothar
is right yet there are no other
objections to this plan nor does the
King build-in precautions to their
approach even with the strong
possibility that this is a trap the army
of Darkness would call to get its
Necronomicon back but the line was busy
with similar requests from other movies
hey Game of Thrones called and I'd like
the hyperrealism back sorry I couldn't
keep a straight face through that day my
bad the shot with the volcano in the
background yeah unnecessary zack snyder
bullshit right there
Durotan told these guys to come when the
Sun was highest but I'm guessing the
cloud cover made that bull Way of
telling time frustrating then foster's
all like dude I had more lines than
x-men The Last Stand dawg
he says orcs are solves everything even
herpes this guy Jason Bourne's his way
through the battle because he's the main
character I think the main non-human
character at least I think but he
somehow has amazing airborne fighting
skills and can take on multiple orcs who
destroyed a whole world back home for a
short while which is still way too long
this movie turns into 300 gotta ask is
there always someone in the middle of a
confusing battle watching after a main
character so they can ex mock into the
situation
don't they have their own worries
roughly too many minutes after the
battle started this guy's powers kick in
I feel like they just took the Empire
State Building Shawn from Independence
Day and CGI two mountain into this thing
and turn the frightened people in to
orcs hold on ah what a whine of can this
guy put his hand through this thing
there's some kind of force field between
him and his fighting son and mostly I'm
just wondering what the does he think
he's doing say one of my buds so these
two and the wounded body guy all wrote a
bird here really those fuckin Eagles
directly take more innocent eyes Houston
isn't their entire culture built around
taking innocent lives they literally
suck the souls out of people to travel
to a new world so they could murder
everyone there too well I call that son
grow East you save the son naming moment
to coincide would be one of the parents
is basically being arrested moment if
love is what you need you must be
willing to travel to the ends of the
world to find that that I'll just try
tinder so the Guardian gives gorona a
magic flower she transports and then
she's talking to Lothar what the fuck
was that about
yep they just stole the orc music from
Lord of the Rings just if you're keeping
score at home for all the theft going on
should have trusted in your chieftain Oh
doom because power his thunder dick was
already taken I guess also wait
this dude's name is doom hammer and he's
not the chieftain that's insane wait for
me I guess I'll just accept that this
bird understands English if only in the
interest of saving time Oh dare you
return here you think there would be a
guard or an obstacle or two that would
keep him from just running into the
counsels area but you'd be wrong no one
beyond the arch council knows of its
existence and it will stay that way why
did you even bother taking him in here
to see it just because he had the page
that said a Scalla died on it the
council thinks this guy is an
unforgiveable quitter but that page
apparently makes you forget all that so
I go in whoa dude you've just learned
about this thing you're still on the
council list why would you go in or be
allowed in but that's exactly what
happens I used the last of my energies
to summon you here does she mean when
she opened the portal or does she mean
when she appeared to him in the library
and made his arm tattoo glow so he would
pick the right book to find that cryptic
message in it because either way that's
the worst summoning I've ever witnessed
is that fucking Glenn Close checking
IMDB typing holy Sh it is literal what
the moment right here as in what the
fuck was Glenn Close thinking or what
some of money did they dumped on her
driveway to get her to do this she's
listed as uncredited so it's conceivable
she had second thoughts right
Khadgar decides to trust this woman even
though she has a hint of green on her
forehead and this movie has done a
pretty solid job teaching me what Ryan
Reynolds already knows green glowing is
bad
always remember from light comes
darkness and from darkness
so basically this whole trip is
worthless all she basically does is tell
him kill the current Guardi and he sucks
and oh yeah that cryptic gas line you
already read in that book remember that
but I'll give you no explanation about
so Guardian was infected by the fell and
that's why he allowed orcs into this
world but how did he get affected by the
fell the problem with this movie is that
either thinks it's getting a sequel and
it'll be able to explain everything
later or it introduces ideas that it
never intends to explain somehow someway
this orc chick is allowed to visit this
dude in his cell
I'd elaborate further but I'm so fucking
over this movie I'm trying to save time
and be concise this would never happen
as annoyed as I am at the spirit romance
this movie would improve dramatically if
we could see a wild thrashing orc versus
humans sex scene right here Square
prison's made of tree branches also
you're telling me this chieftain orc
couldn't Maul the fuck out of the cell's
wall if you want to do it only works on
the simple-minded just like some Jedi
Mind Tricks man this movie rips off all
the movies doesn't it
where's my DS we've got a demon to kill
totally not answering the question for
dramas sake wait she's not is this movie
really going to holy Sh we've got a
blatant Moses ripoff here people you are
the son of Durotan and raka that baby is
too young to remember lady you're just
saying this to pull the audience's
heartstrings cough that baby's all
googoo gaga nipple right now also this
is as good a time as any to mention
they're trying to find and kill you and
your baby they're close you panic fine
but how long off is that baby better off
on its own than with you they're gonna
find and kill you and then give up
looking for the baby not realize you
obviously send it downriver in a
universe with logic your baby is dead
ten minutes after you are and I just
wonder why you don't literally go down
defending your baby as opposed to
setting it at rift and hoping for the
best
Durin's had your plan was weakened you
are traitor you wouldn't believe how
much of this movie boils down to
political posturing speeches it's a lot
I did not expect this movie to devolve
into a CGI rocky film but at the same
time I'm not exactly surprised or
anything so wait did Gul Dan need the
Guardian to create the portal or is it
his own death magic that creates it
because that is something that has never
made clear by this movie at all don't
judge this screaming fan is correct but
it matters not apparently cheating in
the orc magic alt verse will be
tolerated movie treats final battle like
its helms deep or some instead of the
prince caspian battle crap it really is
oh yeah the magical creature made a play
that isn't technically alive but can
still battle is useless without it that
makes perfect sense then
you still in there the real you is
inside there somewhere cliche hey I know
I'm bathing in this evil green liquid
here but I have just enough good guy
magic to form a blue shield around you
because the evil magic microbes take
their time from light comes darkness
from darkness
either he needed to be bathing in green
magic in order for the store which there
was no way for him to know and as lucky
as hell if that's the case or he could
have done this at the very beginning of
the battle and ended it quicker light
darkness darkness light smell is
addictive nature how did he know that
you know what forget it I can forget it
I'm done this movie can go for a log a
really fkin jagged log even though they
were appear to still be a large number
of orcs the humans are still
inexplicably winning this fight so let
me get this straight
these orcs who were having zero effect
on the portal from the other side are
still there
you mean they just knew the portal would
go away eventually I'd have given up
after 10 seconds of beating on magic
blue electricity but these guys decided
just wait it'll be gone soon now the
orcs are winning again this work
strength rely on who has control the
portal or is it just a moral thing well
killing me will make you a hero bring
peace between orcs and humans how just
because she kills you and gets to
survive because of it how in the world
is she supposed to rise to power to
bring harmony between works and humans
and why would humans believe your story
for that matter it's not like I told
everyone before the battle hey if she
kills me don't be mad at her for it it
means I told her to do that I don't want
to stab you in the neck but I have to
face now Lothar will single handedly
defeat the orc army did the writers just
get drunk and make up this last scene as
they went along yeah but why why is
Lothar not dead yet why did they give
him a chance to fight for his freedom I
owe this guy nothing yep he went for the
nuts the dirtiest fighting move in any
time period fictional or otherwise but
on the plus side it brings us much
closer to this thing ending moody is
open-ended and unfortunately this movie
made decent money overseas which means
we might have another one of these
fucking Thanks damn you for box office
Oh weeks later this baby is still
totally alive and still floating down
this river and you know what I'm come
out dude peace
expecto patronum finish mmm sure myself
you will enjoy the feeble hospitality of
the dwarves
hello I'm Peter where are you from
originally Oh me don't try to change me
remember when we would track blood ox
through the frost wing June place the
bullseye womp rats in my t16 back home
there are teen years
my baby
be still don't cry